morning thank you thank you I see a few
iphones out there thank you welcome back
to the apple campus this is the new
macbook pro to tell you all about it i'd
like to invite phil schiller up phil
this is so exciting a new generation
macbook pro it comes in a 13-inch and 15
inch sizes and it is simply the thinnest
and lightest macbook pro we have ever
made first let's look at the 13-inch
macbook pro here's the previous
generation here's the new 13-inch
macbook pro on the right that's
seventeen percent thinner than the
previous generation weighs just three
pounds again the previous 15-inch
macbook pro here's the new 15 inch pro
next to it and it weighs just four
pounds but what's really impressive so
customers open it up for the first time
and look inside because everything is
all new it is a great keyboard I could
talk all day about it but I think you're
probably looking at that area just above
it it's a retina display is multi touch
it responds to gestures and your taps
and makes things incredibly easy to use
we call it touch on it replaces the
standard system functions we're used to
so if you want to set the brightness or
the volume it's easier than ever before
just a slide or tell the touch bar
adepts whatever software you're using so
for example in this case we're in Safari
and now the touch bar is showing us
buttons for our favorite websites well
next to touch bar is another technology
touch ID we're bringing touch ID to the
mac for the very first time the display
in the new macbook pro is simply the
best display we've ever made on a map
compared to the previous 15-inch MacBook
Pro it is sixty-seven percent brighter
as a sixty-seven percent greater
contrast ratio it displays why color
with a 25-percent greater color gamut
the pricing for these three configs are
1499 1799 and 2399 we think this is the
most forward-looking advanced notebook
line we have ever had thank you very
much thank you